diese entdeckung ist ziemlich
revolutionär supraleiter haben das
potenzial die welt wie wir sie kennen zu
revolutionieren materialien die strom
verlustfrei übertragen
doch bisher ist das unter nur unter
bestimmten umständen möglich
beispielsweise bei sehr tiefen
temperaturen
einem forschungsteam gelang vor kurzem
eine spektakuläre entdeckung die
fachleute vertreten dazu zwei schichten
von graphen gegeneinander und spürten
somit eine art magischen winkel auf der
macht das wundermaterial aus zwei grafen
netzen zu einem supraleiter der sich an
und ausschalten lässt klick zum science
fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity klocke nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
und vielen dank für den vorschlag von
samuel aus der telekom community da
erhaltet ihr die videos werbefrei vor
allen anderen und könnt mitdiskutieren
und eben themenvorschläge machen
der link ist hier und da unter mich über
dieses rätsels zerbrechen sich für sich
teams weltweit stand seit mehr als 30
jahren den kopf wie muss ein material
gestaltet sein dass es auch bei
raumtemperaturen strom verlustfrei
leitet wie müssen die atome in solch
einem supraleiter angeordnet sein einer
neuen spur folgt jetzt ein
forschungsteam die fachleute haben sich
mit der kohlenstoff variante graffin
auseinandergesetzt auch bei klicks und
science fiction haben wir ja schon öfter
über dieses wundermaterial berichtet
graffin besteht aus einer einzigen
schicht von kohlenstoff atomen und diese
zweidimensionalität ist tatsächlich ein
kleines wunder denn eigentlich ist alles
mit dem wir in der umwelt zu tun haben
dreidimensional die kohlenstoff atome in
graphen sind ähnlich angeordnet wie
bienenwaben und genau das macht seine
vielen superlativen eigenschaften aus
denn es ist nicht nur 300 mal fest staat
sondern auch härter als diamant doch
dabei ist kaffee in flexibler und
leitfähiger als kupfer und außerdem auch
noch das wohl dünnste material der welt
café wurde im jahr 2004 das erste mal im
labor hergestellt von neun jahren 2010
gab es dann für die herstellung einer
anatomischen lage graphen den nobelpreis
seitdem überschlagen sich die
schlagzeilen zu dem thema so auch jetzt
ein spanisches forschungsteam hat sich
die supraleitung in graphen genauer
angeschaut und dabei neue spannende
erkenntnisse dazu gewonnen wie eine
doppelschicht
graphen supraleitend wird demnach gibt
es nicht nur eine sondern mehrere
elektronen konzentrationen die das
möglich machen in der theorie existiert
dieser verdacht schon etwas länger
doch die experimente der fachleute
bekräftigten diese bislang eher vage
vermutung aber von vorne im vergangenen
jahr 2018 hat ein forschungsteam vom
renommierten massachusetts institute of
technology mit in cambridge
herausgefunden dass sich die
elektrischen eigenschaften von graphen
auf sehr einfache art und weise
verändern lassen denn das café das
normalerweise elektrischen strom leitet
verwandelt sich in ein isolator sobald
zwei der kohlenstoff netze leicht
gedreht aufeinander gelegt werden wenn
dann aber eine spannung angelegt wird
geht sein elektrischer widerstand
verloren graffin wird zum supraleiter in
der fachsprache ist von einem
sogenannten marie muster die rede hier
sind die atome so angeordnet dass die
elektronen sehr stark interagieren und
genau das kann dann diese supraleitung
herbeiführen der studie zufolge liegt
dieser magische winkel bei genau 1,1
grad seitdem ist die hoffnung die auf
graphen als dem supraleiter ruth groß
doch dabei ist nicht zu vergessen dass
das zweilagige graffin nur innerhalb des
labors zu gebrauchen ist denn seine
super leitungs eigenschaft ist nur knapp
oberhalb des absoluten
temperaturnullpunkt es möglich der
forschungsteams weltweit geben nicht auf
bei ihrer jagd nach einem supraleiter
der eben nicht ganz bestimmte umstände
erfordert um dieses talent auszuleben
zu dem magischen graffin gibt es
unzählige theorien aber bislang nur
wenige konkrete experimente doch das hat
ein spanisches forschungsteam eben jetzt
geändert und so kann ein verdacht
erhärtet werden der in vielen aufsetzen
auf basis von theoretischen überlegungen
bereits aufgestellt wurde
ob eine doppelschicht graffin
supraleitend wird oder nicht hängt wohl
vor allem von der elektronen
konzentration ab doch es gibt nicht nur
eine davon die das ermöglicht sondern
mehrere entscheidend ist wohl die zahl
überschüssiger elektronen die sich in
der sogenannten marie zelle befinden das
material wirkt als isolator wenn es sich
um ganze zahlen wie 1 2 oder 3
elektronen handelt die sich in diesem
etwa 13 meter großen bereich befinden
weicht die konzentration davon ab wird
die grafen doppelschicht zum supraleiter
die ursache dafür allerdings ist weiter
unklar
fest steht nur um den magischen winkel
genauer zu unter
buchen ist viel arbeit notwendig denn es
ist alles andere als einfach zwei
graphenschichten dementsprechend
zusammenzukleben einen grafen schnipsel
der nicht größer ist als einige wenige
mikrometer muss vorsichtig auf die
zweite graffin schicht angebracht werden
das passiert mit hilfe eines roboterarms
der mit einem joystick von fachleuten
gesteuert wird mit einem mikroskop wird
überprüft ob das zusammenstellen der
probe erfolgreich war
doch das ist tatsächlich nur der
kleinere teil nach angaben von
forschungen sind es gerade einmal zwei
von 30 proben die für die weitere
analyse eingesetzt werden können also in
den restlichen fällen geht es einfach
schief mit diesen konnten dann aber
bislang bereits einige tests
durchgeführt werden unter anderem wurde
der elektrische widerstand gemessen und
auch die reaktion des materials auf
äußere magnetfelder mit hilfe eines
rastertunnelmikroskops konnte auch die
oberfläche der doppelschicht graffin
untersucht werden
doch die auswertung der ergebnisse ist
kompliziert dazu mathias scheurer von
der harvard university
bisher ist hier allerdings schwer zu
unterscheiden welche der beobachteten
eigenschaften auf unsauberkeiten in den
materialproben zurückgehen und welche
auf echte physik doch die hoffnung
stirbt zuletzt und genau daran halten
die forschenden fest sie sind
optimistisch dass es weiterhin der
richtige weg ist die supraleitung bei
extremen temperaturen zu verstehen denn
danach lässt sich möglicherweise auch
ein material design bei dem dies auch
bei raumtemperatur möglich ist
hochtemperatur supraleitung supraleitung
ja quasi bei raumtemperatur in diesem
video ist die super leitung schon bei
minus 23 grad gelungen ein absoluter
rekord also anklicken anschauen und
unbedingt klicks und science fiction
kostenlos abonnieren nur dann bleibt ihr
wissenschaftlich wirklich am ball also
bis dann bleibt dran